our next question is from Jeremy in
Michigan this is Jeremy from Dearborn
Heights my question for the minimalists
and simpletons is how do you stop buying
Dave Ramsey talks about the stupid tax
and I feel that I must like paying it
even to the point of getting out of
credit card debt to then going back
$30,000 in the whole it happens not only
buying things I don't need or even
really want but buying them over again
because I've already donated another one
in the past sometimes even the recent
past shopping seems to be my life even
if it is killing me Jeremy I totally
resonate with this I found in my own
life that shopping was compelling
because my life was rather
uninteresting and I wanted to comfort
myself with retail therapy why do you
think Michael why do you think retail
therapy is so comforting to people well
I think you just um alluded to it so
this is kind of a I'll try and keep this
answer somewhat brief here's what I'll
say so as part of the scarcity brain I
talked to this guy whose name is Thomas
zental and he's this uh he's in his 80s
he's this old school behavioral
psychologist he's been doing it since
the 60s like he came directly from
Skinner and he's done these experiments
where he can uh basically turn a pigeon
into a degenerate Gambler in about two
minutes so how this works is he all his
pigeons live in these small sort of
sterile cages right their life seems
fine to a scientist but this is where
they live and he gives he puts them in a
bigger cage he gives them the option of
playing two different games in the first
game they Peck a light every other Peck
gets them 15 units of food okay so it's
a predictable game game two is like a
slot machine it's designed to mimic a
slot machine so every fifth peack they
get 20 units of food but it's random so
the light might turn on you know the
food might come out the second peck on
one series it might come out the fourth
one on the next series um if you do the
math it makes far more sense to play the
first game right because if you do every
other one you're getting 15 versus one
and every five you're getting 20 you get
a lot more food by playing this
predictable game and there's this Theory
called the optimal uh foraging theory
that basically says that all animals
will do whatever they can to get the
most amount of food for the least amount
of effort so basically that theory along
with common freaking sense says hey is
like you should be playing the first
game when he puts him in the cages 97.6%
of pigeons choose to play the slot
machine game wow they choose the
gambling game okay and his point
was basically you see that in humans too
we often do irrational things and then
he tells me okay like here's this
experiment we did though that offsets
this what we do is we take pigeons and
we put them in a big cage like it's this
giant cage that's designed to mimic the
wild it's supposed to be exactly like a
pigeon would live in the wild so they
get a hang out with other pigeons they
go up on rocks and roofs they have to
actually work they're exactly like
they'd be living in the wild and then he
puts them back in the cage and every
single pigeon chooses the rational game
the game that gets them more food and so
then he goes when you think of humans
today when we don't have our needs met
when we're not living kind of like we
should having to put in effort in life
and live like this kind of wild life
that we evolved in uh we look for
simulation from somewhere else so
there's this Theory called the optimal
stimulation Theory and it basically says
that when we don't get enough
stimulation in our lives we go looking
for it other places and that's exactly
what this is leaning into so when you
think of humans it's like we live very
differently than we did in the past
right we evolved in Landscapes that were
hard we had to go work for our food we
were exercising all the time just
through life and living it we were
Outdoors on and on and on and and when
you think about how we live today we
don't have that level of stimulation in
our life anymore we really don't and so
we go searching for it elsewhere and so
I think you start to see things like
some people fulfill that stimulation
through shopping some fulfill it through
drugs some through alcohol some through
tick Tok some through slot machines and
I can tell you that for sure because I
live in Las Vegas and the town wouldn't
exist if this weren't a thing and so
that's kind of a long way of saying um
people search for stimulation and if SHO
is your stimulation what else can you
get stimulation from and fulfill that
underlying thing that you're trying to
solve for in a way that doesn't lead you
to accumulate a bunch of stuff and a
bunch of debt and I mean that that's the
other thing is and he was talking about
Dave Ramsey I mean Dave Ramsey would
certainly agree with me when I say the
best way to get out of debt is to stay
out of debt that is often the problem
that I see with people's closets as well
they clean it all out they don't know
why they did it they just felt like they
were supposed to do it or they're
supposed to get out of debt they're
supposed to organize their house and
then a week later a month later a year
later it is reutter or you're back in
debt because a you didn't replace it
with anything meaningful and so you
default to your defaults as capil Gupta
says that what happens is my default is
shopping gave me a little burst of
happiness I know it wasn't actually
working for me but it's working more
than doing nothing and so because my
life isn't hard in a weird way Jeremy's
making his life harder because it makes
him feel alive would you agree with that
right it gives him gives him something
that feels like a win right it feels
like effort it feels like so another
thing I talk about in um scarcity brain
is this idea of um the scarcity Loop so
I live in Las Vegas as I mentioned and
um the weirdest thing you see in Vegas
and there's a lot of weird things you
see in Vegas let me just say that
is uh slot machines okay they are
everywhere gas stations grocery stores
airports bars
restaurants and people play them around
the clock like I will get groceries at
6:00 a.m. and there's people playing
slot machines just play and play and
play and to me being a journal I mean my
job really is to observe something and
if it doesn't make sense then I go okay
well what's up with that let's figure it
out so long story short as I you know I
see these people playing slot machines
and I'm like how the hell does that work
because everyone knows The House Always
Wins but you've got thousands and
thousands of people playing these things
non-stop so this long story short
through you know talking to this guy who
puts me in touch with this lady who puts
me in touch with this lady I end up at
this place called um Blackfire
Innovation and it's in Las Vegas it's on
the Ed Edge of the desert it's a brand
new Cutting Edge Casino but the catch is
is it's not really open to the public in
a sense that normal casino is it is a
behavior laboratory so it's a fully
working brand new casino but it's used
entirely for research and uh while I'm
there I talk to this guy who's a slot
machine designer and he basically tells
me okay like here's how a slot machine
works it works on the system that I call
the scarcity Loop okay so it's got three
parts it's got opportunity unpredictable
rewards and quick repeatability so you
have an opportunity to get something of
value in the case of a slot machine it's
money uh unpredictable rewards you know
if you keep playing you'll get that
thing of value but you don't know when
and you don't know how big it's going to
be right so with the slot machine you
play the wheel spin Anything Could
Happen nothing something or like oh my
God I can retire now right and then
quick repeatability you can repeat the
behavior immediately for as long as you
want so that is what makes gambling so
compelling to people but the important
part and why this big research lab
exists is that you can put this loop
system and all kinds of other things and
capture human attention and drive us to
do behaviors that are seemingly
irrational in the long run so for
example it's really what makes social
media work uh it's in dating apps the
real unlock of dating apps was using
this um it's in sports betting apps it's
in shopping to bring it back so shopping
is a lot of shopping is now leaning into
this Loop where if you think about
shopping it's like if I'm um our Callin
here like I have an opportunity to get
something of value or at least distract
myself but I don't know what it's going
to be and I don't know how good it's
going to be so I go out into the
internet or whatever it might be and I'm
searching for that thing think it's
going to be this I'm reading reviews I'm
and oh my God there's a lightning deal
on this bam that's just like a jackpot
and then I can repeat that as often as
possible because the internet is endless
I mean it's the exact same architecture
as a slot machine I think there's also a
component here where we tell ourselves
I'm going to be different you said that
everyone knows that The House Always
Wins but there are the exceptions
there's someone who's so cunning or just
so lucky that they're able to win and I
think that's the story that I told
myself when I was climbing the corporate
ladder was I started to get closer to
the guys who I aspired to be like I
wanted to be a sea level executive and
and continue to climb that ladder but as
I got closer to them they weren't bad
human beings but they were kind of well
they were really miserable I had one
boss who was on his third divorce and
second heart attack and he wasn't even
50 yet
and I realized that I'm telling myself a
story and that story is but I'll be
different I'm following the same recipe
I know I'm going to bake the same cake
for some reason in my mind the story is
don't worry I will be different if I get
what he has I will be happy even though
it didn't make him happy of course I
must be different what's behind that
well part of that is it's unpredictable
right it's um I mean I will say that
unpredictability it captures attention
of every single animal like if we if
there's a question that you might get
something of value but you don't know
exactly how valuable it's going to be
our attention focus is in every single
time and I do think to your point about
stories we all like to think we're
terminally unique right uh unfortunately
a great term unfortunately we're not um
and often times you have to you learn
that through going through the processes
now at the same time to your point about
um gambling it's like yeah some people
walk away with more money than they came
into the casino with but the longer you
play the house always win I mean the
math just doesn't make sense you can get
a rare win and if you leave right then
you will get more money than the casino
the longer you play You're eventually
GNA lose you're essentially talking
about winning the lottery then but then
the difference with slot machines or
even with um shopping is if you win the
lottery one once but then you go take
your hundred million and buy a hundred
million more lottery tickets you're
probably still not going to win a second
time and that is the pernicious aspects
of gambling or shopping or these things
that promise rewards they're diminishing
returns even if you do get a minuscule
reward or even a big reward up front I
hope you enjoyed that highlight from the
minimalist private podcast if you'd like
another highlight check out this video
if you'd like to watch the minimal
episode check out this video or if you'd
like to dive deep into full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast head on
over to patreon the link is in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free